I'll take care of that man because he's my
neighbor and he's my best friend. That's
$25,000 laying there.
I got an insurance policy on him. It's
against what he owes me. I love the fact
that at 81 in 2023, martin Scorsese
is still making movies that aren't just
good, but in some ways are just as
thoughtful and provocative as the movies
that put him on the map in the first place.
His work now is a little more deliberate and
contemplative. Was he murdered?
Don't know. And maybe doesn't have the whiz
bang pop of some of his earlier work, but I
think he's still actively luring audiences
into a confrontation with the heart of evil
and kind of our own complicity with that
evil, which has been a big theme in a lot of
his films from the beginning. Can you find
the wolves in this picture?
There's a deep sense of horror and dread
lurking throughout Killers of the Flower
Moon from its opening moments until the very
end. I think this movie finds Scorsese
focusing more on the intimate humanity of
the people impacted by the evil he often
examines. Scorsese is transporting his
gangster milieu into the kind of Western
true crime context, but I think critic
Richard Brody was correct when he said this
movie is really more like Phantom Thread
than it actually is like a Western. It's
most concerned with the humanity of the two
characters at the heart of the story.
One of the best, most subtle performances
I've ever seen from Leonardo DiCaprio and
Lily Gladstone has incredible presence in
this role and does so much so subtly with
every moment she has on screen. Perhaps most
profoundly, though, despite its roots as a
true crime story, it's not a crime thriller
and it isn't even very suspenseful. I've
never written before that the overarching
tone in a movie was one of anguish,
but I think it applies here, and there are
some true stories where this is what is
required to tell them in a way that doesn't
distort things for the audience into
something that is unrecognizable from the
truth of the situation. Yes, it's a long and
difficult watch, but Scorsese and his
editor, Thelma Shoemaker, both have a great
grasp on pacing and flow, and I think it
uses its running time effectively. It draws
you deeply into one of the most gut
wrenching stories you'll see all year.
Killers of the Flower Moon is the best movie
of 2023, I think, at least.
I'm going to say that's my number one. It's
that time of year again where the critics
collectively decide that it's reasonable to
declare the best movies of the year before
the year is even over. We're going to start
with a list of my ten favorite films from
the year, which is not exactly what I
promised in the title. I promised you the
best movies of 2023, which is kind of
different from my favorite. Which movies are
the best in any given year is kind of an
impossible thing to figure out. But I do
want to try to answer that question for my
own curiosity and yours. So if you stick
around to the very end, I have a separate
list of the best movies of 2023, and I'll
explain how I came up with that list once we
get there.
So just so we can understand you better,
what exactly are you opposed to? I don't
want to be some culture war person. I don't
want to be controversial. Okay, well,
yeah, this is going to go right against what
you're saying right now, but there is a
chance, we think, to get you on Tucker
Carlson this. So how much social media has
started to take over our lives, has created
this very weird world that we live in now.
And I feel like we're just starting to get
movies that grapple with this world in an
interesting and insightful way. Celebrity
influence and public accountability are all
concepts that are kind of evolving and
transforming in this new landscape. And so I
was very excited this year to see a very
funny movie with Nicolas Cage at the helm.
This is just one example, but they mentioned
Sprite. Sprite that plays with a lot
of these concepts in what I thought was a
pretty insightful and comedic way. There's
like a hundred messages on here. Probably
Claire's article. She must have linked it to
my profile or something. Somebody wants to
interview me. Why are you so excited? Why?
What's wrong? Dream Scenario is a hilarious
and genuinely insightful comedy about
celebrity in the 21st century. So many of us
kind of long to exist in the collective
dream, and for Paul Matthews, the sudden
burst into fame he receives when he starts
appearing in a lot of people's dreams is a
dream come true for him until it starts to
turn into a nightmare. This is one of those
patented good Nicolas Cage performances that
I love. He's genuinely great in this role.
There are so many little jokes here that
really struck a chord with me. I love all
the weird dream sequences, and the movie
probably has the most on point satirical
representation of an Internet marketing
company that I've ever seen. That recording
is not reality. It is a
part of it. Maybe if you have an extreme
moment in life, an emotional peak, and you
focus on it, of course it crushes
everything. It may seem like irrefutable
proof, but actually warps everything. So
much of life is deeply complicated and
ambiguous, and often our stories offer a
kind of escape hatch for that ambiguity,
offering us a greater sense of objectivity
than what we get in real life. A lot of
times, Anatomy of a Fall is a pitch perfect,
naturalistic courtroom drama that really
finds its dramatic core in that ambiguity.
And when you see this, what do you think?
I don't know. I'm not a spatter analyst,
where most stories, especially courtroom
dramas, kind of dangle ambiguity to create
suspense and then entice us with narratively
constructed relief from that ambiguity,
this movie really finds its place in the
pain of that very ambiguity itself. There's
a certain horror in knowing that some
questions in life are kind of technically
unanswerable, and yet we strive to answer
those questions because not two would be
unbearable. Such is the work of trying to
stitch together an objective sense of what
happened in the past from little clues,
forensics and limited witness accounts.
Anatomy of a Fall is impeccably crafted and
well performed. It really never dragged or
missed a beat. For me,
one of the biggest reactions I felt from a
crowd in a theater all year was during a
very small moment in Fallen Leaves, and it
was a reminder that when a movie has a
smaller dramatic landscape and smaller
stakes, if it's made well, the dramatic
gestures in the movie don't actually feel
smaller or less significant. Instead, they
kind of expand to feel more profound. In
Fallen Leaves, the dramatic thrust of the
film rests on forgotten names,
quiet encounters, and lost jobs. It's a
deadpan, dark romantic comedy from Finland
that's a bit evocative of like a Jim Jarmish
movie, especially his older stuff. The lead
performance from Alma Poisti is beautifully
restrained, and this movie had probably my
favorite use of music in any movie this
year. One of the things I was really drawn
to this year were movies that just had a
great vibe, that felt good to spend the
running time within, and this is one of
those. It's beautifully shot, there's great
music, and it's not hitting you over the
head with its existential profundity. It's
also something incredibly rare these days,
which is a movie that clocks in under 90
minutes. So if you need a quick, engaging
watch that's as melancholic as it is funny
and delightful, check out Fallen Leaves.
Y'all what?
Perhaps the single shot that I've thought
about the most from any movie this year is
this very simple yet quietly powerful one
from past lives.
This is another movie that, like Fallen
Leaves, I think was beautiful to just spend
time within. It's less comedic and not as
dark as Fallen Leaves, but it has a similar
sensibility for the quiet drama that kind of
pervades everyday life. Are you attracted to
it?
I don't think so. I don't know. I don't
think so. The film follows two characters
over the span of decades, and it's a
beautiful portrait of how we have an
evolving relationship with our childhood and
our past. Here that relationship is
represented through a lost romance. But even
if you don't have a childhood romance that
you've left behind, the sense of nostalgic
wonder about how things would have been if
you had taken a different path is something
that I think we all face as we grow older
and inevitably make choices that alter our
lives in significant ways. It's an
impressive directorial debut from Celine
Song that like, after some last year,
cements this director as a name I will be
looking out for in the future. Why would you
want to play someone who you think is a bad
person? Are you kidding? I mean, pick any
great role. Medea or hetta.
Gobbler. Tony Soprano.
Precisely. Cameron it's
the complexity, it's the moral gray areas
that are interesting, right? In a strange
way, May December is kind of the little
bastard cousin of Killers of a Flower Moon.
The material is a bit lighter here and
definitely presented very differently.
I don't think we have enough hot dogs,
but both movies are about how harm can
masquerade as love and use a very interior
perspective to examine that dynamic.
They're also both kind of ultimately about
how stories and film can sensationalize
reality in a way that discards the victims.
Todd Haynes'latest work is a strange little
metamoden piece, one that both luxuriates
in kind of the craft of acting even while
it's critiquing, and kind of deconstructing
how that craft can be used in a very
exploitative way, the movie is kind of a
tonal chameleon. It sparked this huge debate
on Twitter about what melodrama and camp
are, which I'm not really going to get into
here, but I will say whatever it is doing,
it seems to pull off its balancing act
seemingly effortlessly, teetering between
its funniest and most disturbing moments
without flinching. The performances from the
three leads here were some of my favorites
of the year and this might be a career best
for Natalie Portman it
proceeds there tinged magla
for the habit what
does it mean to see without seeing? When we
talk about taking a photo, there's this very
possessive element to the language we even
use to describe that act capturing an image
can kind of impose the perspective of the
person taking that image on reality,
sometimes so strongly that the capture is
blind to what is literally in front of them.
Godland is a beautiful period portrait of
Iceland and the people there and within that
it also captures the image of a priest who
is blinded by his own perspective. The
priest is not really interested in seeing or
hearing, only imposing his vision on the
people he encounters and imposing his vision
on himself. What he fails to see the movie
brings to our attention with its beautiful
stoic, kind of lingering gaze. It's a film
with a fascinating kind of boiling internal
tension and it's beautiful to look at with
some of my favorite cinematography of the
year in
college I started a monograph on Carthage.
I'd like to finish that someday.
Monograph is like a book, only shorter. I
know what a monograph is. Why not just read
a book? I'm not sure I
have an entire book in me. Girls talented
your husband complete you can't even dream a
whole dream, can you? The holdovers
is the kind of movie this year that I didn't
realize I wanted until I saw it. I love a
great snow movie, and they are few and far
between. It's been a while since the
Christmas movie canon has been updated. The
Holdovers instantly felt like it could rank
among some of the best. The Holdovers
doesn't just look like it's from another
time because of the beautiful period
cinematography and set design and
production. It also feels like the type of
throwback story that we would have had
a lot of in the but which are kind of few
and far between today. It's heartwarming and
sincere, but without ever becoming corny or
overwrought. And it's not the deepest, most
profound or most impressive filmmaking I've
seen this year, but it's perfect at what
it's trying to do, and it's the kind of
movie I can see myself watching again and
again in years to come. Understand me never
lived outside God's house what so bella's so
much to discover. And your sad
face makes me discover angry feelings
for you. By far, the most wild and inventive
thing I watched in 2023 was Poor Things. I
love a movie that has no clear touchstone,
a movie that you can't describe by comparing
it to other movies. Yorgos Lanthamos's films
in general are kind of like this. I mean,
try describing the lobster to someone, but
what's crazy about Poor Things is you can't
even describe it by comparing it to
other Yorgos Lanthamos films. What the
range from a movie like The Killing of the
Sacred Deer to Poor Things stylistically,
is just kind of absurd. Poor Things is
probably the biggest swing I've seen in
terms of just doubling down on absurdity
since everything everywhere all at once.
And at least for me here, it's kind of
working. The movie is grounded by this
weird, technically very impressive
performance from Emma Stone, where she kind
of evolves developmentally from infancy
to adulthood throughout the course of the
film. Mark Ruffalo is hilarious in this
movie. The set design, costume design and
cinematography are all out of another world.
But I will say this one definitely isn't for
everyone. It's one of the grossest and
darkest movies I've watched this year.
Don't be fooled by sort of the candy colored
production design. If you don't have a
stomach for other Yorgos Lanthimos films,
this one will not be any different. It's
ultimately a strange ode to the kind of
chaos of the world and all the different
ways we try to navigate that as we mature
and grow as humans. No movie
had me smiling and giggling maniacally in
the theater the way The Boy and the Heron
did the new Hayo Miyazaki movie from Studio
Ghibli. Getting to witness the magic of a
new Miyazaki film in theaters was not
something that I was expecting for 2023,
but I was delighted to experience it. The
movie as a whole originally titled How Do
You Live in japan has that sense of profound
wonder that kind of sneaks up on you partway
through the film in the way a lot of
miyazaki films do. It doesn't oversimplify
its examination of life, childhood trauma,
and how we process those things, but it does
explore them with a kind of childhood wonder
that is as lighthearted as it is sincere.
What I loved most, though, was just the
absurd joy I got from just some of the
beautifully silly ideas that are in this
movie. I've never seen parakeets this scary,
fascist and goofy, and it's a great reminder
that sometimes just imagination and beauty
can be one of the most powerful elements of
a film. You feel different?
Hey. You feel different?
I don't feel anything at all. Me neither.
If you've been following this channel for a
while, you know I'm a big fan of Wes
Anderson's work. I've made many videos
covering his style and different films at
length. And while I think his last few films
have definitely driven his visual aesthetic
to greater and greater heights, this year's
movie, Asteroid City, for me, felt like an
evolution in terms of how personal
and thematically rich his storytelling can
be. In some sense, it's a pretty chaotic
film. It has this huge cast. So much is
going on. It touches on a lot of things
thematically, and it weaves in and out
through all of these things as well as
layers of narrative. But this chaos for me,
like everything everywhere, all at once,
last year captured something about the way
the current world feels, and the movie is
ultimately about the characters in the story
navigating that chaos from the interior.
It's a movie that keeps unfolding with more
depth every time I watch it. I watched it a
bunch of times and made a video earlier this
year breaking down my interpretation of it.
And even after doing all that and spending
hours with the film, examining it, there
were still a lot of layers and elements to
it that I didn't recognize until I saw other
people talking about how they interpreted
it. Wes Anderson's work continues to be
polarizing, but I personally love it, and
I'm glad he's doing his thing as boldly and
unapologetically as he does. This is the
movie that struck the deepest emotional
chord for me personally this year, and it's
the one I watched the most. And so you know
what? This is my number one. I'm changing my
mind. This is my number one movie. This
year's list was more difficult for me to
compile than last year's. There are so many
movies that could have nudged their way onto
this list on a different day if I was in a
different mood while I was recording this.
Barbie was way more profound and
inventive than I was expecting from what is
basically a toy commercial, and I was very
impressed with what Greta Gerwig did within
that framework. Oppenheimer, I think, saw
Nolan kind of reaching new heights,
technically as a filmmaker. Spider Man
Across the Spider Verse is one of the most
beautiful animated films I've ever seen,
and I love that they're continuing to evolve
this style. Even from the first film, david
Fincher's The Killer had the most
viscerally, hard hitting fight scene that
I've seen in any movie in a while. And I
loved Kelly Reichart's quietly dramatic
showing up, although that one was basically
on my list last year. But these are just my
opinions about what I liked. These are just
my favorite films. What about the best
movies of 2023? Is there
a way we could figure out what the best
movies of the year are? I don't think really
truly, because it's all kind of subjective
ultimately, but we could compile a bunch of
different critics lists, as well as Rotten
Tomatoes Letterboxd Box Office IMDb to
see where movies rank across all the best
of the year lists. If you want the complete
list of all the sources I pulled from and
how I used them to rank the films, I've made
a post in my newsletter that I'll link to
down below. But here, according to as much
data as I could collect in a reasonable
amount of time, are the top ten best movies
of 2023.
I think everything on this list is good.
The only thing I haven't seen is Zone of
Interest, but I've heard a lot of good
things about that because I drew from a lot
of critics lists. This is probably weighted
a little more heavily towards the critical
opinion rather than the popular box office
opinion, but I think this would be a pretty
good list to go off of if you wanted to make
sure you saw the Greatest Hits of 2023.
But I think there's a problem with lists
like this that kind of try to average
everything out. They can be useful. But
something I realized looking at a bunch of
individual critics lists, is that most
people on their list have at least one or
two movies that are kind of a wild card.
Movies that aren't showing up on anybody
else's lists. These are the movies that
maybe didn't hit big with a general audience
or even with critics as a whole, but which
for some reason connected very directly and
deeply with the person making the list. All
the movies on this list are movies that
showed up a bunch of times on all the lists.
So if you watch these, there's a good chance
you'll think they're good movies. But if you
only watch these movies, you'll miss out on
those little movies that come out that it
feels like maybe nobody else gets, but which
you just personally love. Seeing what other
people like can be helpful and fun and
help you determine what you want to watch
and don't want to watch from the year. But I
think it's a good reminder that especially
if something looks interesting to you. It's
good to take a chance sometimes on movies,
even if they're not the most popular or most
critically acclaimed, because you might be
surprised by what you find overall. I felt
like 2023 was a solid year for cinema. But
more than anything, in 2023, I felt grateful
that I live a life where caring about movies
is something that I get to do in so many
ways. Watching, creating, and caring about
these stories is such a luxury and a
privilege, and I'm really grateful that this
is what I get to do for a living and that
you've taken the time to join me here. And
if there's a movie that's not in this video
that you loved, I haven't had time to watch
everything. So tell me and the other people
in the comments why you loved it so much and
why we should watch it.